londres est en pleine interview dans la
vraie vie ce dollar man alors andré est
ce que dans votre vraie vie il ya des
coups de théâtre pauvre
ah oui j'adore ça vous arrive quand oui
oui ouais je sillonne les rues dans
l'espoir qui aura un coup de théâtre au
croisement avec votre femme fait relâche
ce lundi non maintenant les 3 contiendra
dix ans resterait pour le saas et les
trois coups derrière
dans les trois coups non et rentrent
plus dans la vraie vie vous arrive de
vous jouer la comédie à vous même à moi
même peut être pas trop non
non aujourd'hui que la journée à bas où
ça peut arriver ouais ça pète le jeu est
assez agréable aussi celle des
formations professionnelles dans la
vraie vie vous avez déjà pensé à changer
de partenaire oh oui bien sûr ouais bien
sûr oui ça peut arriver comme ça c'est
facile de rêver hein
le principe un nom quand on la voit
encore en salle est-ce que dans la vraie
vie vous changez souvent de décor oui
j'aime bien ça voyager toute façon même
changer de décor il suffit de rester
chez moi pour changer de décor assez
facilement